so if you have an iPhone in the US you
may have noticed that on the latest
16.3.1 update Apple flipped a switch on
everyone's phones that makes charging
slower is what some of the headlines
would say but the real story is actually
really interesting so if you look now in
battery health settings there's a new
setting called clean energy charging and
what it does is it tries to reduce your
carbon footprint by only charging when
your house is likely to be pulling from
cleaner sources of energy based on your
local electrical grid that is kind of
wild luckily you can override it you'll
get a notification that says it's not
charging and waiting for clean energy
you can bypass it but the interesting
thing about this one is this setting is
opt out meaning if you go to check your
settings it's going to be on by default
now you know charging your one iPhone at
slightly more optimized hours won't make
a big difference to your own personal
carbon footprint but Apple flipping a
switch for millions and millions of
iPhones at once will probably in total
make a really big difference to total
energy saved a rare W for the
environment I also can guarantee this
would be in a slide at the next Apple
keynote